you might even have diabetes unknowingly
a lot of the people who are undiagnosed
aren't visiting their doctor they're not
tracking any data whatsoever so they're
walking around with with diabetes not
knowing it which is a silent killer
increasing her risk of cardiovascular
disease and all these other metabolic
issues I'm educated I'm an exercise
physiologist I'm diabetes educator I'm
living with diabetes how could I not
share this
information my guest today is Drew
Harrisburg an exercise physiologist a
sports scientist and also a type 1
diabetic which is a diagnosis that Drew
received when he was 22 years old that
sent him on this journey to understand
this particular disease and how to
thrive along with it as both an athlete
as well as an educator through his
online platform Drew's daily dose and
his many appearances on our mutual
friend Simon Hills podcast the proof in
this conversation we go deep on Drew's
personal story as well as the physiology
of diabetes we discussed the differences
between type 1 type two and pre-diabetes
and also the differences between what
can be prevented or reversed versus on
the other hand managed through lifestyle
movement mindset and of course nutrition
which leads us into how diet impacts
blood glucose management what is
important to understand about this and
what isn't we also talk about Drew's
take on the usefulness of continuous
glucose monitors as well as Drew's
search for the optimal diet to manage
his own condition and improve the lives
of those he coaches which is a journey
that took him from paleo to keto to wait
for it Whole Food plant-based and it's
coming right up after a quick word from
the sponsors who make this show
possible I'm extremely proud to
introduce you to our newest brand
partner on check out their lineup of
super comfortable sleek and durable
pieces for yourself at
on.com super nice to finally meet you
thank you for doing this uh we are
sitting in our mutual friend Simon Hills
uh
studio um so shout out to Simon thank
you for opening up your space uh to let
us record today and you're somebody drew
who came on my radar because of our
mutual friend Simon I think youve been a
guest on his show something like 12
times or something like that I'll stop
counting but it might be around quite a
few right so clearly uh a trusted Source
on a show that's literally called the
proof uh so you've been vetted and uh
I've been looking forward to talking to
you for a long time I think you're
personal story is really compelling and
in your own words talk a little bit like
introduce yourself and and tell us a
little bit about like who you are and
and and and what you do well firstly
thank you for having me on the show I
mean it's it feels so weird doing it in
my home Hometown I would not have
expected us to be doing it in Bondi but
it's awesome that you're here and I'm
excited to share my story with your
audience I've I've shared my story with
Simon's audience a number of times but I
haven't spoken about it for a long time
because you know what happens when you
tell your story over and over it becomes
like a story you tell rather than
something that you really feel in the
moment so yeah I'm excited to to go
through it with you today so I mean I
guess the best way to to introduce
myself would be to go back to guess life
before diabetes as as I like to say when
I was uh when I was 21 or about 22 I was
diagnosed with type 1
diabetes which was something that I
actually I knew a little bit about it
because I'd studied to become an exis
physiologist and we learned a lot about
diabetes and how to treat and manage it
but until I actually was diagnosed with
type 1
diabetes you really you don't understand
the depth of of a condition or a disease
until you're living it
so before being
diagnosed I I grew up in Bondi I had the
best upbringing you could have you know
I finished school and I decided I want
to pursue a a career in music so I was
playing gigs around Bondi and all over
Sydney and I was actually making money
playing music which I never thought
would
happen I was traveling the world I was
Carefree cruising on autop pilot life
was honestly just too good to be true
and I was aware of it I didn't take it
for granted at all um but there was this
sort of transition period which lasted
for about 6 to 12 months where I noticed
that my health was I just knew that
something was wrong it was hard to
explain what it was just this feeling
this innate feeling that there was
something wrong and at that time i' I'd
already finished University I graduated
as an exercise physiologist or Sports
scientist and I was in the process of
getting my accreditation to become an
exercise physiologist and as part of the
accreditation you have to do a certain
number of like clinical hours at a
hospital or
physiotherapist so I remember this one
day I was doing my accreditation at this
physiotherapist and I caught a glimpse
of myself in the mirror this sounds so
vain but I I saw myself in the mirror
and I had this moment where I was like
I'm really skinny like I'm I never used
to be this skinny like what is what the
hell is going on I've lost all my muscle
and I sort of talked myself out of it
but I was like this is weird I'm going
to start eating more food and try to
bulk up I was playing rugby as well at
the time and obviously it's a very
physical sport you need to be strong and
you need your body weight to be up so I
jumped on the scale at the Physio and I
was around 70 kilos whilst my pre-season
weight or my normal healthy body weight
was 83 kilos so I was like 10 to 12
kilos under where I should be without
any change in your diet no change in my
diet training hard you know you know
focused on maintaining a strong body so
I could play this
sport so I started to eat more food and
really started just anything and
everything was coming in and I then
finished that placement at the
physiotherapist and I had to start
another one at a hospital in um just
down south and I was working at a
cardiac rehab Ward but to get into that
position as the I guess the trainee
student to get the accreditation you sit
through an interview sort of like at a
desk just like we are now face to face
with the head of the cardiac rehab
facility and I'm sitting there across
from this
guy and all of a sudden I'm like dozing
off my eyes are shutting it feels like
my eyelids is just heavy and I'm like I
cannot believe I'm falling asleep face
to face right now with the guy who's
trying to get me this position so I can
follow my dreams with becoming an
exercise physiologist like what is going
on here I've got my pen under the table
like jamming it into my leg doing
anything I could to stay awake and I'm
just I'm gone like I can feel that I'm
going to fall
asleep somehow I get the position after
that interview the guy probably felt so
sorry for me he's like let's just give
this kid a shot anyway I get the role
and I start working as this training
student at this cardiac rehab facility
in the
hospital few weeks go by and I'm every
time I drive home it's probably like a
4-minute drive or more maybe 60-minute
drive in traffic I'm falling asleep with
the wheel and I'm thinking to myself
what is why am I so tired like how is
this possible that my eyes can shut not
only face to face in an interview but
while I'm driving my car surely I'd have
this like safety mechanism in my brain
that would just go hey you could die
right now stay awake anyway I fell
asleep a few times driving home over the
next few weeks and then there was this
one day where I was driving through the
Cross City Tunnel this tunnel that
brings me back to the Eastern suburbs
and I wake up inches from the the side
of the tunnel wall I've drifted across
across a lane and I've had this like
micro sleep I slam back into my lane
windows down screaming music up doing
anything that I could do to stay awake I
finally make it through the tunnel I
pull over at Rush Cutters Bay this
little area outside of the
tunnel and I fall asleep in my car
intentionally I put my seat down I shut
my eyes and I wake up like 2 and a half
hours later or
something as soon as I wake up I call my
parents they're doctors and I say
there's something seriously wrong I need
to go for a blood test immediately I
just fell asleep driving I fell asleep
multiple times over the last few months
it's time to get checked out so my mom
sends me for this long list of blood
tests she just Stacks everything in I
mean we were concerned what kind of
doctors are your parents my mom's a
general practitioner and my dad is an
eye surgeon or
opthalmologist so my mom had you know
been sending people blood tests for
years and she knew what to look for but
for me she just said look let's just
test everything let's just rule out
Sinister stuff we didn't know what it
could be at this stage no idea so I go
to get my Bloods done they take vile
upon vile blood like I am dry by the end
of it and we get these results back you
know just a few days later cuz we we
slapped an urgent sticker on it and it
came back really
quick and most of my results looked
relatively normal but there was this one
marker this one biomarker that came back
out of range which was very strange for
somebody of my sort of Age and and you
know health status so to speak right and
interestingly this biomarker is not
something that most GPS would test for
but my mom just threw it in there as
just another Hail Mary let's see what
happens it's called your
hba1c it's a three-monthly average blood
glucose so it's sort of it's this marker
that tells you what your blood glucose
control has been like over the last 3
months and this number came back not
just a little bit high but in the
diabetes territory
right I think it was 6.6% and you want
it to be below
5.5% so we were that was the first red
flag we were like why has this number
come back so high we better look into
this a little bit
further now the irony is my dad who's an
opthalmologist was at the time working
alongside RPA Hospital the diabetes
Clinic there one of the best diabetes
centers in the world and he spoke to the
professor there and said listen my son
just got this Blood resolve back he's AG
A1C is a little bit
elevated what should we do should we be
concerned about diabetes so they said
listen go get another blood test and
test for autoimmune
antibodies which are these immune
antibodies that essentially show up if
your body is attacking itself and were
the two main ones for diabetes that we
tested were Gad Gad and
ia2 which were markers of this
autoimmune attack and they're meant to
be below 10 mine came back in the
thousands so when you get when you get
this result back of these two positive
tests for these two autoimmune
antibodies but you don't have a family
history of type 1 diabetes your chances
of getting type 1 diabetes are
25% so I get this result back we see
these numbers and we go in for a meeting
with the professor the endocrinologist
the uh diabetes educator and we sit down
and they say to me look you've there's a
chance that you're to get diabetes one
day it's one in four it could be in 5
days 5 years or maybe not at all but
what we're going to do is we're going to
give you this blood glucose meter and
you're going to take this with you for
the next two weeks and you're going to
measure your blood
sugar before bed when you wake up before
and after every meal at random times
throughout the day just collect some
data let's see what's happening and
we'll keep an eye on this thing come
back in 6 weeks we'll reassess we'll
make a plan
so you know but that's not exactly
comforting in light of your hba1c result
and the fact that you're falling asleep
behind the wheel like that you know
you're in a you're in a sort of uh acute
situation in which you need to figure
things out pretty quickly right so at
this stage there was no treatment
protocol there was no solution or plan
forward it was just collect data look
for Trends and patterns and we'll figure
it out soon like you said I still felt
like I was still underweight I was
exhausted I mean the the other signs by
the way of type 1 diabetes or
undiagnosed diabetes they called the
four
TS thirst excessive thirst so waking up
in the night to drink you're drinking
all day long you can't stop drinking
needing to urinate and go to the toilet
multiple times throughout the day and
the night and all of these things are
happening to me excessive hunger weight
loss and exhaustion right so I was
experiencing all of these things and I
go home with this blood glucose meter
and I start to test you know prick my
fingers and I would do it at all the
times that they told me I should do it
and there was this one morning where I
woke up and they said to me if you ever
see a number above I think it was 11 a
random blood glucose above 11 or a
fasting blood glucose above
s call us immediately come back into the
clinic so I woke up one morning and I
saw a
7.7 and I was in complete denial I I
told I convinced myself that it was a
mistake there's no chance so I I did log
it down in this book they gave me and I
carried on with my day I you know went
to the gym I ate the meals that I would
eat I would check and the rest of the
day was normal I continued for weeks and
weeks and then eventually it was time to
go back into the clinic so I'm sitting
down with a diabetes educator and I show
her my numbers and I say look this is
the numbers that I've I've got and I was
I kind of like prompted her I was like
I'm going to be fine right you know i'
I've got mostly normal numbers here she
saw the seven she said that is is an
interesting you know number there let's
why don't we give you a new meter that
we've just got the accuracy is a bit
better it's a bit smaller keep tracking
for another two weeks so she goes out to
the back room she brings in this new
blood glucose
meter and I'm sitting next to my dad and
I'm across from her and she's opens the
box and she's like let's test your blood
glucose now to show you how to use this
meter it's a little bit different so she
Pricks my
finger squeezes out a little drop of
blood takes the sample and then she's
holding the device and she's waiting for
it to show up with a number and I just
see her face just
changes and she looks at me she says
when was the last time you ate a meal
and I said I had a piece of toast just
before I came here on the way
over she said I'm afraid to tell you
you've got type 1
diabetes and that was the moment right
there that I was
diagnosed face to face with this
diabetes educated with my dad next to me
who' spent his career treating and and
diagnosing I conditions you know people
that had had type 1 diabetes or type 2
diabetes uncontrolled for
years and he was in complete denial he
said there's no way there that's got to
be a mistake why don't you get a new
meter so she went out the back she
obliged she came back in with a new
meter we went through the same process
pricked the finger same result my blood
sugar was 16 at the time
which is about uh maybe 350 or something
in in milligrams per deciliter so you
know four times the normal
range so I got diagnosed with type 1
diabetes in the most bizarre
circumstances sitting in this Clinic
that my dad had pretty much worked at
for decades with the team that knew him
and knew me and it was just such
a surreal experience like you know the
phrase the world caved in mhm yeah it's
just not something you expect as a young
vibrant athletic guy at the beginning of
his life and his career who's used to
you know doing whatever he wants you
know that that that like sort of
youthful uh you know sense of of being
uh you know Unstoppable right and so you
you suddenly this this Unstoppable
energy that you have comes up against uh
an immovable Force so your world changes
overnight but I think it would be good
to talk a little bit about what diabetes
is uh the differences between type one
and type two I think there's a lot of
confusion out there uh misconception
certainly with respect to T1 uh being
incident to lifestyle decisions uh very
different from from type two so diabetes
is basically you know your body's um
disregulation of your ability to
metabolize glucose in a healthy way but
it's so much more than that as well so
like what is the clinical kind of way to
describe this condition yeah I mean
diabetes is an umbrella term for these
multiple types that manifest in
completely different ways but the
symptoms are the same so they all share
a common symptom which is high blood
glucose or
hyperglycemia but the way in which that
hyperglycemia comes to fruition is
through different Pathways so in type 1
diabetes it's an autoimmune condition so
the immune system attacks and destroys
the cells of the pancreas that produce
insulin the beta cells right once those
beta cells are destroyed you cannot
produce insulin so you have to you have
to administer it exogeneously so through
a pen or through a pump so every day for
the rest of your life you have to give
insulin through either device with your
meals you have to give a basil dose
before bed that sort of sits or some
people take it in the morning but
essentially the basil dose is this
background insulin that's floating
around for like 24 hours and then you've
got a meal time insulin which is like a
rapid acting you know if I wanted to say
eat a bowl of fruit like I've got on
this table I would have to look at this
bowl of fruit calculate how many grams
of carbohydrates are in it understand
what my carbohydrate to insulin ratio is
do the math wind up the pen and give
that dose right right so what's
interesting is that there are different
types of insulin and different uh ways
in which you can administer that um
you're not wearing a pump like I I know
other people that have T1 they're
wearing a pump like you you do this
differently so I'm interested in why
right right the pump is delivering
insulin either drip feeding it on a
basil dose so all day just dripping it
out or if you want to eat a meal the
same thing you just plug it into the
little computer you hit the button and
it sends that insulin uh that sends a
signal and then the insulin is
administered into your body MH so it's a
different system to administer it but
the problem of going low is the same
with both see so it can still happen to
anyone it does it's extremely common and
that's the one thing you want to try
avoid is these terrible lows because
acutely that is the biggest danger of
type 1 diabetes the the chronic high
blood glucose is more of a long-term
danger that's something that causes the
r rhinopathy the blindness kidney
disease nerve disease but it takes time
takes years to develop that but in an
instant if you go too low you can
completely lose Consciousness and end up
in a coma m so going back to the
definitions though so type 1 diabetes
your body stops producing insulin
because the beta cells aren't working
now most people get diagnosed in a way
that was very different to my experience
most people are rushed to hospital in
ambulance conscious or unconscious and
likely in a coma MH with keto acidosis
so the blood glucose gets so high for so
many months unknowingly and kids will
feel this immense thirst and then
they'll start drinking soft drinks to
try quench their thirst which sends
their blood glucose
right so they go to hospital with keto
acidosis whilst my experience was very
different and you know when I think
about
it I may have been dealing with this
pathogenesis unfolding for 6 to 12
months but I think my lifestyle was
holding holding me from getting
diagnosed sooner so type two on the
other hand is not a problem with insulin
production initially it can be later but
initially it's an issue with insulin
resistance so the the action of insulin
doesn't work properly so the role of
insulin is to attach to the cells of
your body it's like a key that unlocks
this Gateway so glucose from the
bloodstream can enter the cells of your
body CU that's where we need that energy
to go so when you have type 2 diabetes
you develop insulin resistance so the
insulin isn't working properly but your
pancreas is still producing insulin but
eventually over time they can also
experience pancreatic beta cell
destruction or burnout where they stop
producing enough insulin so you can be
you can become an insulin dependent type
2 diabetic and in pretty much all cases
of type one you're insulin dependent
right so being insulin dependent as a
type two diabetic is the result of uh
long-term you know
chronic uh living with that condition
that leads to that result but I it just
feels like they should be they should
have separate names
confused about this and then when I you
know like often you know now because
type 2 diabetes is on the rise and I
don't have the statistics with me right
now but it's quite
staggering exent to which yeah people
are are falling prey uh you know to this
disorder and the number of people that
are becoming pre-diabetic it's really a
metabolic disease which distinguishes it
from a pancreatic disorder that is type
one right exactly the numbers are
staggering I think globally and these
numbers are from 2021 the international
diabetes Federation or one of those
organizations put out some numbers I
think it's 537 million people globally
have diabetes um 50% are
undiagnosed 50% so you've got this
silent Insidious condition that's you
know present amongst 50% of those
numbers they don't even know it which is
where I think the
GM could play a role right we'll get
into that there's a lot of controversy
around that and I'm looking for some
clarity and I know you've thought a lot
about that but let's put a pin on in
that for for the moment um and just
return to you know kind of the the
timeline here which is you get diagnosed
as a young person um I'm interested in
in what what you were told the prognosis
is now we see all kinds of people being
athletic and running marathons and
there's a whole type one you know
professional cycling team where
everybody you know it's like we there's
a permissiveness or a sort of
understanding that you can live an
active lifestyle with this condition uh
was that communicated to you at the time
or did you think suddenly your life is
over as you know it right yeah I'd say
the latter it felt like a life sentence
initially um I'm sitting in that room
and the world caves in it's just I can't
explain the feeling
of life's over it's I'm done like I have
no the future was just so
Grim like the even it's hard to explain
but like the color of the world changed
like the saturation was like pulled out
of the environment everything it was
like gray um so they told me that you
can still live a great life but my your
life expectancy is going to go down you
probably won't live as long your risk of
cardiovascular disease is significantly
increased the long-term complications
are very frightening and they showed me
this like caricature of a person who is
poorly managed for multiple decades and
they are blind they've got their they're
on kidney dialysis and they're missing a
limb I mean like like that's what I
needed to see in that moment I mean what
a ridiculous thing to to attach your
future to they said that you can
exercise but it's very dangerous and you
need to learn how to do it safely and
then they said one of the most dangerous
things about type 1 diabetes is the ad
ministering the insulin and getting the
dose wrong if you overdose it can be a
life sentence for real you can you can
die seizure coma the list goes on so
they actually sent me home without
insulin they said look keep monitoring
for a few days let's see these Trends
and patterns and then we'll figure out a
therapy an insul therapy to match your
lifestyle cuz everyone's a bit
different so they sent me home and I
mean that night was that was dark I mean
I cried myself to sleep my family were
were an absolute mess especially being
doctors and having an insight into this
condition they just they knew what the
potential complications were and we all
just were hoping that I wouldn't be
another statistic you know so had a
rough night wake up the next day and I'm
like okay I'm going to do what the
doctors told me I'm going to track the
the next movements of my day and get
some data of of blood glucose and log my
book and you know I was begging for
insulin therapy cuz I knew that it would
make me feel better that my blood
glucose would come back into the normal
range
that I would probably start to gain my
weight back and I just want I was like
please give me insulin like I really
want this they're like just be patient
we'll get it to
you so the next day after being
diagnosed this was the crossroads in my
life this was the game changer so I
remember eating breakfast I ate you know
a meal that I would eat back then it was
probably like oats and yogurt and banana
or something and I checked my blood
glucose and it spiked up to 25 which is
450 50 in Mig per deciliter huge five
times normal
range and I remember seeing that number
and just feeling so deflated like I I
felt terrible in my own skin already but
then just seeing that number was just
another reason to sort of hate this
position I was
in anyway I I went uh to the gym which
is what I would usually do and I put my
glucose meter away smashed out of
workout and for those 60 minutes I was
just in my happy space I felt amazing I
still managed to do a good workout full
body workout you know got a good sweat
on for 60 minutes or so I got out of the
gym and I checked my blood glucose again
expecting to see the same number because
at that stage that that I didn't I
didn't know that anything in your life
in the day-to-day activities of your
life could influence your blood glucose
right so I check my blood sugar
and I see that the numers back into the
normal range so dropped from 25 down to
about five and I was blown away I could
not believe it that was the the first
time that I felt this like little bit of
hope all of a sudden the color was
coming back into the world around me and
I felt like hey actually this is pretty
powerful stuff I can manage my condition
potentially just by exercising this is
incredible right like a little spark of
agency that you could exert what's
interesting is without insulin without
the you know insulin being the the the
molecule that opens the gate that allows
glucose access to the cells how does
exercise provide that role in the
absence of insulin well this is what is
so fascinating about the human body is
there is another mechanism by which
glucose can enter the cells of the body
I will say the caveat here is that
because I was in my they call it the
honeymoon phase which is such a
ridiculous term for this phase but when
you're newly diagnosed you may still
have like 3 or 4% uh pancreatic function
at that point so I may have been
produced producing just a little bit of
insulin right so small amounts but just
enough mhm but the other mechanism is
really where the magic is so I mean it's
such a great question like how did the
GL how did my blood glucose go from 25
down to 5 like how did that even happen
so as as we said before insulin acts
like this key that opens the the gateway
to the cell but it turns out there's
another mechanism which is called
non-insulin mediated glucose uptake it's
got a few names contraction mediated
glucose up take exercise induced glucose
uptake but
essentially the act of Contracting your
muscles sends this message inside of the
cell to send it's called glute for a
trans a um a transporter a glucose
transporter that sort of resides inside
of the cell when you contract your
muscles it sends this Cascade down into
that cell and this little transporter
translocates to the cell wall and acts
as this Gateway so if if anyone has
pre-dyed diabetes insulin resistance or
you know type one or has high blood
glucose or I mean in everybody in
healthy people too it's the same
mechanism so you contract your muscles
and you get these glucose gateways
opening up MH which allows this free
access for glucose to enter the cells
completely independent of insulin so you
don't have there's no insulin cost at
all in that case it makes sense uh from
a survival and evolutionary perspective
to have this kind of backup generator
right like hey these muscles are
Contracting they need glucose like I
don't know what's going on with the
insulin over here but like we're going
to have to you know get the supply going
yeah exactly so you know in a fight ORF
flight situation or anything like that
where the muscles can't be dependent on
wherever the insulin happens to be or
not be in order to function exactly and
and the you know the unique thing about
this this mechanism is that it's sight
specific so depending on which muscle
you contract is where that glute for or
glucose transporter will do its work so
if you only go to the gym and do calf
raises and bicep curls compared to the
person who does a full body workout all
training all the major muscle groups the
glute for translocation will be very
different between the two so if you're
if you have diabetes and you want to get
your blood glucose under control a full
body workout is going to be a way better
way to open those gateways than just
isolation work you know doing a bro
workout so that workout that I did was
just so powerful for me cuz it gave me
this sense of you know
responsibility or agency as you said but
also a tool this is my first tool that I
figured out was like I can do this I can
control my diabetes as long as I
exercise every day which became a bit it
might be that might be overstating the
case very much so which I didn't realize
I didn't realize at the time but I made
some big is to do this right made some
big errors off um at some point
obviously you're you get on the you know
insulin uh program and all of that um
and you learn how to administer it
responsibly and safely and I'm sure
there was a whole learning
curve every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra right on the trail
and I just got the new NextGen Cloud
Stratus 3 for the road I'm loving those
but an also has this incredible line of
lightweight high performance apparel
that it's just beyond anything I've
previously dawned it's like this second
to none Second Skin I love to rock the
sweat wicking Ultra te and the ultra
shorts which have this pocket right at
the base of the spine that perfectly
anchors your phone no jiggle I'm just so
proud to partner with an and I love
their vision for the future where their
gear is fossil free and engineered for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com walk me through kind of the
evolution of developing greater and
greater agency through lifestyle choices
yes with exercise but even beyond that
that have kind of informed how you live
with this day-to-day and and sustain a
healthy active LIF style so life became
a big experiment you know and I was I
was already trained and accredited as an
excise physiologist so I had this
understanding of the science and I knew
about how the body worked but I'd never
walked the Walk of someone you know
living with diabetes so I began to just
test every and at this stage as well I I
was still using the glucose meter I
didn't have a CGM I've only had this for
a couple years and I've been living with
diabetes for like 12 years now so I was
doing 15 to 20 finger Pricks per day
but I became obsessed with collecting
the data so I was just pricking my
finger all the time I didn't want an
hour to go by without knowing what my
blood glucose was right and they'd
offered me this technology but I I just
I wasn't ready to wear my condition on
my body you know I was I was in hiding
for the first I want to say even a year
I did not want anyone to know that I had
diabetes I would go to the bathroom to
give my insulin if I was out at a
restaurant I would never prick my finger
in public I'd go to the bathroom to do
that too or go to my car or I didn't
want anyone to know what I was dealing
with you know I just I wasn't hadn't
identified with my new being and my new
condition that I was going to be
carrying with me for the rest of my life
and I want to say I felt ashamed but I I
definitely felt icky about it you know
and I know it was not my fault at all
forgetting it but I wasn't ready to wear
it confidently and proudly so the first
year was hard a lot of hiding it but a
lot of self-experimentation and I would
check you know my blood glucose before
and after certain workouts and I would
notice that depending on the type of
workout the blood glucose response was
completely different mhm and that was
the mistake I made early I mean it was a
blessing and a curse but you know that
pivotal moment where I did that great
workout and brought me back into
range in a way set me up for some
failures because I saw exercise as this
you know as a hammer basically and
everything everything was a nail every
time the blood glucose was up got to
hammer it right but what I didn't
realize was certain cases required a
different tool and the hammer was not
going to do it like I was trying to
tighten screws with the hammer like it
just you need to find other tools so I
mean a couple of learnings that were
that depending on the intensity of the
exercise you know your blood glucose can
actually go up so you know for the first
week or two after you know doing that
great workout I would wake up in the
morning and go for a fasted Sprint
session at Bondi on the the soft sand
and I'd finish the session and my sugar
would be up to like 20 which is the same
blood glucose that it was when I ate
that carbohydrate
meal and I was just so confused I was
like hold on a second I just used
exercise in that case and it worked
perfectly but today it's made my sugar
go up and then I realized that caffeine
you know from drinking coffee can
stimulate adrenaline which also you get
this glucose output so this the
high-intensity Sprint training the
caffeine
in a fasted State early in the morning I
was layering these two things on top of
each other and causing my blood glucose
to go even higher as the body has this
ability to to put uh endogenous glucose
or glucose that's stored in the body
into the bloodstream through the liver
so I was turning this liver tap on
unknowingly in the mornings and I would
you know wake up with a blood glucose
that was normal and after my workout I'd
be in the 20s again so I mean just so
many little failures and learnings along
the
way of course nutrition I mean that was
the next thing that I had to try tackle
and the way I sort of fell into the
nutrition side of things was I just did
a simple Google search just being
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes what diet
should I eat or something or like how to
treat or cure type 1 diabetes with diet
which obviously you can't treat or cure
it but I landed the first thing I landed
on was uh was a Paleo way of eating
which you know when you compare it to a
standard Australian diet or standard
American diet it's a step in the right
direction certainly and your diet
leading up to that point was very stand
typical yeah right I mean of course
health conscious but by no means you
know Whole Food focused like I would
kind of eat a bit of everything so I
feel into this paleo way of eating and
instantly some great results you know my
carbohydrates per day were roughly say
150 gr per day so not too too low but
you know just right in that sort of
Sweet Spot um I focus on Whole Foods
I eliminated whole grains and legumes
and dairy but I was eating fruit and
vegetables and lots of meat and eggs and
chicken lean meats fruit veg right no
grains and no lagum right so and no
processed foods obviously and no Dairy
exactly yeah so in comparison to you
know just a
typical you know person's way of just
mindlessly eating whatever obviously
you're going to have amazing
improvements from that right yeah and
what I noticed was in the first maybe I
mean the timeline's a little bit blurry
now but within say 4 weeks or so my
insulin requirements had come down quite
a lot so in the beginning um you know I
was given this I was told by the
educator to give a basil dose of insulin
which is every day you're going to give
this sort of large dose that's going to
sit in your bloodstream for 24
hours that dose came down by about 50 to
60% after a month or so on this paleo
diet so the basil had come down and then
my other insulin the short acting one
with meals had also come down so per
unit of insulin I could now metabolize
more glucose which was really
interesting so again another great tool
so I discovered exercise as this
wonderful tool now I've got nutrition
and at this point I felt very
comfortable with where I was I was super
happy with my diabetes management my
hb1c was great close to normal not quite
there yet but very close you able to put
weight back back on and go out and live
your active life in a pretty normal way
yes the weight came on rapidly and to
the point where it came on a little bit
too quick I got very fluffy very fast
which makes sense because I was
essentially starving for those months
because although I was eating a lot of
food it wasn't getting into the cells of
my body it was sitting in my bloodstream
and I was either excreting it through
the kidneys urinating the glucose out um
or it just wasn't getting it was just
building up in the bloodstream so you
you know once you start taking insulin
which is a very anabolic hormone you're
going to gain weight extremely quickly
and I got fluffy and I was doing a lot
of modeling in my early 20s and all of a
sudden this I mean this was a hard thing
to deal with because I was getting no
work now cuz my body had completely
changed the modeling industry loved the
skinny you know fashiony editorials
looking body and now I was really out of
shape um and in fact there's a huge
overlap with um type 1 diabetes and
eating disorder especially in women the
stats are crazy like 30 to 40% of women
with type 1 diabetes develop an eating
disorder and I'm not surprised why you
know it's well the disease the condition
itself makes you like sort of
hypervigilant about what you're eating
and then you're taking this on anabolic
and it's creating weight gain so it's
not surprising it's going to have that
you know impact and a lot of a lot of
women intentionally don't take their
insulin so that they can lose the weight
and then you can imagine what happens
there to that blood glucose it's a
slippery slope and it's it's I've known
many girls who have gone through this
it's really it's horrible and guys and
guys I I certainly there was a period
where I also developed some disordered
eating well you're getting fluffy to use
your word and you're like well I know
how to fix that all I have to do is cut
back on this other thing it's a lot
easier than trying to you know regulate
your dietary choices and to add to it if
my blood gluc was in range I would just
I would just skip meals I would go you
know what I'm in range I don't want to
go high I'm so scared of these longterm
complications of going high I'm just not
going to eat for like 10 hours and just
stay in range longer then by the end of
the day I mean a huge calorie deficit
I'm not nourishing my body with anywhere
near the number of nutrients and
macronutrients that I need and then I'm
going the other way so that I dealt with
that for a long time and you know what I
did some damage for sure to my health in
many ways way and again just these
little failures I kept tripping over and
figuring things out and dusting myself
off and I I I found my way back to a
path that was really good for my health
but you know the first year or two was
extremely difficult so you cut onto this
paleo diet and and lifestyle and that
seems to be working why not stick with
that for the Long Haul what happened
good question well I sort of immersed
myself in the diabetes Community online
and I I became
you know somewhat of a of an advocate
for healthy living with type 1 diabetes
and I I was talking to people on
Facebook groups and Instagram and all
these things and people would ask me all
the time for my opinion on certain ways
of eating for diabetes and one of the
questions I kept getting asked was what
about keto why what do you think of the
keto diet for type 1
diabetes and being someone who loves the
self- experimentation I found it hard to
give an answer having not tried it
myself so I I thought you know what I'm
not going to give my opinion on the keto
diet until I've tried it so I sort of
dived into that I started a keto diet
and I was documenting it in real time on
social media I was posting about on
Instagram and I was waving the flag I
was an advocate I was I was raving about
it cuz the first two months again my
insulin requirements came down even
further my insulin um to carb ratio was
even though it was very low low carb
diet but I was taking hardly any insulin
and I was keeping this beautiful just
Flatline in range
everything looked amazing and what
exactly were you eating like what was
the breakdown what did that look like so
I mean 75% of the calories were from fat
um I definitely did a Paleo kind of keto
diet in terms of I kept a lot of Whole
Foods a lot of leafy greens non-starchy
vegetables broccoli
cauliflower you know I try to keep it
vegetable heavy I wanted to keep fiber
in there right but like completely non-
glycemic vegetables right right and and
when you say 70 I mean 75% fat so what
what is that what is that like you're
putting uh you know you're putting
coconut oil in your coffee and I didn't
go to that extent saturated fat like
what you know what exact how did you
consume 75% of your calories in fat so a
lot of olive oil on salads with half an
avocado a piece of salmon nuts and seeds
on top and an egg mhm and then a big
base of leafy greens broccoli
cauliflower those kinds of things so big
like salad bowls with lots of fat sauces
and some protein I was consuming a lot
of coconut oil uh fatty Meats chicken
beef um you know I was eating a fair
amount of saturated fat but I would say
I was doing a healthier keto diet than
what you do see other people right that
sounds that doesn't sound so bad I mean
that in comparison to you know videos
You'll see on line of people just
literally taking a bite out of a stick
of
butter that guy there's some you know
wild stuff out there right but that's
still a lot of fat a lot of saturated
fat but had this amazing impact on your
ability to to Really flatten that curve
and and manage your diabetic condition
and this is something that a lot of
people with type two or any kind of
metabolic disorder or just in general um
uh people are experiencing
success with they feel right and it
makes sense as to why it works you know
you've got this condition where glucose
is something that's hard to
metabolize and you're eliminating
glucose from entering your bloodstream
so you're going to stay in range for
longer which also means your requirement
for insulin is lower right so it just
makes sense and for about two months it
was great and I was telling everyone
about it and I was recommending it until
I hit a brick wall where I noticed that
every morning my fasting blood glucose
was a little bit higher and would happen
day after day week after week for a
couple months and I was very persistent
I was like I'm going to ride this storm
I'm going to see what happens how when
you say until like how many how long
were you into it when that began so two
months into the diet I started to see my
fasting blood glucose Elevate and then I
stayed with it for about 2 months so
what was happening was my my liver
overnight was pushing glucose into my
bloodstream right so I mentioned that
glucose tap I was that tap was on all
night and when the glucose was in my
bloodstream there was no way out it
wasn't getting into the cells of my
muscles or anywhere else that could
bring my blood glucose back into the
normal range so I would increase that
basil insulin which is that background
insulin I would just give a little bit
more each night until I'd find the dose
that would stabilize me but I could I
just couldn't get it under control so my
basil was going up my insulin but my
blood glucose wasn't coming down so I
was at this position where I felt like I
was getting resistant to the insulin it
wasn't even working anymore which is
pretty frightening because that is the
one tool that I need to keep me alive
I'll literally die without it mhm so
during the day as well my short acting
insulin doses were going up and it just
wasn't working and there was this one
day where I was I was actually on a
photo shoot and the photographer was
like are you okay like you just don't
look vibrant and I was it's cuz I was
dealing with a high blood glucose that I
couldn't get under control so before the
shoot I gave a large dose of insulin
checked my blood glucose 2 hours later
hadn't moved so I gave another big dose
of insulin checked again it was not
moving so I got to this place where I
was like I think I'm actually resistant
to the exogenous insulin that I'm
administering which is a pretty scary
reality right and
then that was where I kind of knew I had
to shift gears it was time to to look
into this like what is going on and this
is where Simon he'll enters the
conversation right and what's
interesting is is that you are doing
everything that you think is right the
conventional wisdom out there for people
that are contending with this condition
is that carbs are the enemy and the best
most effective way to manage a diabetic
condition is to eat a low to no carb
diet to focus on fats and proteins and
this will allow you to kind of manage
your blood glucose levels which is
effective until it's not right and I
think what's pernicious and kind of
beneath the surface here that we're
going to get to is this idea that that's
the Curative path but in reality it's
quite pernicious because all it's doing
is masking your body's inability to
metabolize glucose because you've never
you're not exposing you're not exposing
your body to glucose um so you're not
actually dealing with the problem you're
removing kind of the external symptom
ology uh because the minute that you do
expose your body to glucose you quickly
realize like it's it's it's completely
incapable of doing it so basically
you're you're in this persistent state
or you're kind of pursuing this path
blind to you know kind of the reality of
what's going on and this journey that
you've been on and we've talked about
this on my show before with other people
like Robbie and Cyrus Etc um there's a
whole other way of looking at this that
um you're soon to discover by Dent of
our friend Simon right yeah that's
exactly right when you can
achieve normal blood glucose levels and
normal insulin
requirements in the absence of
carbohydrates in your
diet you're you're essentially just it's
a Band-Aid solution to a degree it can
still be a solution for some people cuz
if you can maintain that long enough and
you don't run into the same hurdle that
I did which I don't which it happens to
a lot of people I've got dozens of
messages over the years but some people
can keep that up for a long
time but that is just a like you say
it's it's your you're you're you're just
masking these these symptoms right
because as soon as you reintroduce the
carbohydrate or that trigger you're
going to see the real identity of what's
going on so whilst on the other hand if
you can achieve blood glucose control
that's normal with with good insulin
sensitivity and normal insulin
requirements in the presence of
carbohydrates that is the true insulin
sensitivity that is true and robustness
right exactly exactly so you know I was
I was posting online about the keto diet
and typ 1 diabetes and how to manage it
and all this stuff and you know
Simon he he flicked me a a Instagram
stories of a doctor who had been at a
conference and delivered a talk with
these lecture slides was it Michelle
mcmackin yes it was yes so she had been
talking about a plant-based you know
High carbohydrate approach to managing
diabetes and I'd never heard of Whole
Food plant-based at that point I didn't
actually understand there was a whole
movement there I to me it was just you
paleo keto just that's interesting in
and of itself how would you not have
even known didn't even know yeah cuz uh
there's like a whole world there I
guess that's a larger conversation about
how our information silos can can work
AC cross purposes with
youing us to ideas I guess if you're in
the Paleo or keto kind of Wormhole
you're not hearing a lot about other
options or Alternatives I I literally
had never heard of it he said he sent me
a message with these lecture slides and
he wrote have you considered and he
wrote wfpb and I was like w what is that
I had to Google the acronym to even see
what it meant did you know Simon from we
had mutual friends got you see him down
at the beach or whatever I just you got
like you know cross down like working
out to you know ah that guy looks fit
yeah like we we' obviously we knew of
each other and I knew him as the um the
nutrition guy and I knew I didn't know
really what his message was somebody I
thought he was a chef to be honest CU a
friend of mine was working with him and
taking some photos and I saw photos of
him with food and I thought he was a
chef anyway he introduces me to these
lecture slides and I had a look at them
and I read through it and I was like wow
so there's another way and this way has
all the carbohydrates in the diet and
they're claiming that the control is as
good if not better than these other
approaches I guess being the
self-experiment that I love to to be I'm
going to have to give this a
crack that contravenes everything that
uh you know we kind of hear around how
to manage this condition carbs are the
enemy right the solution can't can't
reside in like eating a bunch of carbs
to manage this like that doesn't make
any sense at all it does feel like mixed
messaging doesn't it and you know people
get really agitated and activated when
you uh propose that as an idea right I I
mean look carbohydrates depending on the
context in which you have them can be a
trigger of high blood glucose excursions
that is a fact that is true but what
they're not telling you is
that the degree of insulin sensitivity
that you have will dictate whether or
not you can tolerate carbohydrates right
so you you need to be insulin sensitive
you need your your insulin to work
properly and the way to achieve good
insulin sensitivity is number one you
got to be a healthy body weight body
composition matters you need a fair
amount of muscle on your body cuz that's
the glucose sink those are the glucose
sponges that soak up the glucose the
types of fat that you eat will impact
your insulin sensitivity so if you have
a very high saturated fat diet and
you're eating carbohydrates which is the
standard Western diet essentially that
is a recipe for disaster sure so if you
add car carbohydrates into that system
in that context you will see these
glucose spikes and you'll blame the
carbohydrate immediately because you'll
just say I ate the banana or I ate the
whatever it is the candy and my blood
glucose went up but what what you're
failing to see in that in that context
is if you swap those fats and replace
them with unsaturated fats lots of fiber
Whole Foods that you can now tolerate
those carbohydrates a lot better than in
the context of high saturated fat intake
so it's really really important to
understand the different macronutrients
and how they mix together and how how
they play so you have a receptivity to
trying this to to experimenting um and I
think it's worth noting that that is not
unrelated to the grace with which Simon
approached you he didn't he didn't ping
you and like shame you or say you're
getting it wrong or brow beats you he
just said hey maybe check this out like
I think that there's something something
about that that is worth noting because
the way that we communicate in our
various you know dietary circles with
the silos and the judgments and the
owning of the other side and all that
kind of stuff is not really productive
at all uh and I think you know Simon's
just kind of very gentle like hey man
check this out you're a scientist here's
the paper I'm not telling you what to do
like hey maybe maybe read this yeah that
that's exactly so the way he did it was
gentle he sort of just gave me this nice
little gentle nudge in the direction of
now you take responsibility you do the
reading and see where you end up yeah
and I'm not attached to whether you
change or do anything differently even
if you read this paper and he didn't
oversell it either he didn't say trust
me if you follow this diet you'll have
the best insulin sensitivity and you can
manage your diabetes way better than
this he just let me do the work and I'm
glad I did the work because where I've
ended up is a great place but you know
essentially I deci I just
decided that day that I was going to
dive into becoming fully plant-based and
I was going to let go of the keto which
was the other end of the spectrum it was
quite a you decided that but after
experimenting though you must have said
well let me check it out and see if this
is even effective for me after reading a
little bit about it I mean how else can
you go plant base without going fully
like cuz I was already pretty much there
cuz I was eating a paleo diet that was
you know
80% plants like I was eating a lot of
plants already but you didn't have a
like a bowl of fruit like that right
there sitting next to no no that that
that would that would not be even in the
house no chance um and just remember
being paleo you're not eating whole
grains or legumes so you know carbs were
I was I wouldn't say I was fearful of
them but I was certainly not embracing
them and I I I had victimize them in
certain ways myself because I'd seen you
know sometimes I'd have these spikes and
I it's very easy to blame the
carbohydrate M but I guess the decision
to go plant-based I I was like I'm just
going to do it 100% I could have edged
there sure I could have just slowly
taken out the salmon off that plate and
then swapped it with whatever beans or
and then kept the eggs in and kept a bit
of but I just wanted to go full in to
see the the impacts on my blood glucose
management because I just
remember at that time I was again in a
in a place of turmoil where my blood
glucose control wasn't great right at
the end of that keto di my blood glucose
control was not good I wanted to fix it
as quickly as possible and you know the
exposure from highs saturated fat keto
diet to a lower saturated fat more
unsaturated fat high carb diet I'm going
to see straight away right the
difference yeah you're you're your your
numbers are going to are going to
reflect the reality pretty quickly right
and I was I was petrified of eating
carbohydrates at first I thought I was
going to spike immediately I hadn't
eaten whole grains of legumes in like 7
years 7 years with no
whole grains um cuz that's how long I
was on the paleo diet for about 7
years and fruit I mean I started to add
in a lot of fruit and I I I accepted a
couple of things there were these two
realities that I
accepted and I surrendered to number one
I'm going to lose all my muscle because
I'm not going to be eating any protein
and number two my blood glucose is going
to be very high for a number of weeks
probably that's that's what I thought
was going to happen uhhuh and what did
happen
blew my mind so within a few weeks my
insulin requirements and my insulin
sensitivity was the best it had been in
a long time so I all of a sudden my my
muscles were able to soak up the glucose
again that was in my bloodstream my
insulin requirements went down and down
and down the insulin to carbohydrate
ratio which is an indication of your
sensitivity to insulin improved beyond
what you know actually the best that it
had ever been so it was pretty good on a
Paleo diet but when I removed the
saturated fat and got it down to you
know roughly 10% of total calories up
the unsaturated fats I could tolerate a
fair amount of glucose so that that
ratio was improving a
lot I can almost hear the uh
outrage of of you know the person who's
listening to this who is experiencing
positive results on a keto diet um so
explain how you account for that like
why is this happening because it
contravenes everything that I thought
was true and false when it comes to um
diabetes and when I say that I'm we're
talking about type two here as well like
the experience that you're having or
um the experience that you're having
would would not be dissimilar for
somebody suffering from type two is that
correct correct yeah very similar the
truth
is you
can you can have good diabetes
Management on a keto diet that is the
truth you can also do a keto diet that
is healthier than the one that you see
like you say on social media of a guy
eating a stick of butter pouring coconut
oil and butter into his coffee and
eating bacon and eggs all day and a you
know a carnival style keto diet you can
eat a high fiber Whole Food based
ketogenic diet and you can achieve good
diabetes management for a long time but
some people don't as well right so
different individuals are going to react
differently to certain diets and even in
the case of those people that can keep
that keto diet up for a long time when
they decide to reintroduce carbohydrates
even if it's just you know on a cheeky
weekend or every now and then the
ability to tolerate glucose goes down
and it happens in healthy people it
happens in people with type two type one
that is just how the human body works is
your tolerance for glucose goes down
when you were fully eliminated from the
diet and you increase your saturated fat
so it's just nice for people to know
that there is another solution you don't
have to like some people stick to this
keto diet for years or decades but they
feel like a slave to their diet and they
feel like they have to follow that way
of eating because it is treating their
condition without even knowing about
this other solution so I don't want to
tell anyone what to eat but I just want
to say there is another way you can do
this and if you do remove saturated fat
or at least limit limit it to about 10%
of total calories you can regain that
insulin sensitivity your carbohydrate
tolerance will go up and you can eat the
fruit you can eat the banana you can eat
the grains and you you're not always
going to see this spike in your blood
glucose but you also seem to be
achieving the goal which is to uh you
know be in a situation where your body
can tolerate the carbohydrates that you
have that um you know robustness that is
lacking on a keto diet because you're
just avoiding that exposure yeah I think
a lot of people with type 2 diabetes in
particular they go on a low carb
diet remove carbohydrates from from the
system and they say that they have
achieved remission or even reversal they
think they've reversed because they come
off the medication their blood glucose
goes back to normal they wake up in the
morning their fasting glucose is normal
their postprandial or post Mill glucose
is normal the A1C goes down they may
come off insulin if they were um
dependent on it for a while CU they may
still have some pancreatic beer cells
that are
working and then they they think I've
done it and then all of a sudden they
add back the carbohydrates and it shows
up again so you've got to you've got to
understand that again the absence of
carbs from the diet are going to show
you a blood glucose and Insulin picture
that may not represent the true
robustness of the system like you
mentioned whilst in the presence of
glucose if you can handle glucose you
can handle carbohydrates Ates and
achieve the same numbers as the people
who are completely eliminating the
carbohydrates to me that is the true
yeah then you're in not just remission
you're in a journey of reversal I mean
is that overstating the case it's not it
can it can absolutely happen if if you
have type two diabetes you can't reverse
type one I'll just say that now once
you've got type one at this stage
there's no cure you cannot reverse it
but if you have type two diabetes and
you can tolerate carbohydrates you have
completely normal blood glucose your
pancreas is still working you've got the
beta cells that would be reversal so you
can reverse type two in certain cases if
your beta cell function is burnt out and
you don't produce insulin that's a
different story now you can't really
reverse it that's where staying on a low
carb diet long term could work for
people because they don't produce
insulin so keeping glucose out of the
system you can keep them in range for
longer right so you adopt this
plant-based Whole Food plant-based
approach like how
quickly before you started to uh you
know perceive these results and realize
that you were on to something pretty
powerful maybe two weeks in my numbers
were back to normal I mean two that
sounds like even when I think about it
now that's very fast I couldn't believe
how quickly it happened and then it just
slowly sort of you know plateaued in
terms of the gains it wasn't just linear
and you know it s sort of plateaued a
little bit and I was able to make
maintain that I'm 5 years in now and
I've maintaining the same instant
sensitivity I'm eating you know hundreds
of grams of
carbohydrates I didn't wither away and
lose all my muscle you know my my I was
very happy with my gym performance and
my sporting performance and how I feel
and just the whole list you know I I I
was very very nervous about a few things
there and thankfully I I was I was wrong
right your ability to build lean muscle
mass and and you know be the fit kind of
you know exercising fiend that you are
right to maintain my strength and still
you know you have this vision of of
you're going to be frail and your bones
are going to turn to dust and you're not
going to be you know it's just not the
case it's so wild I mean I had uh Robbie
Bavaro and and Cyrus the mastering
diabetes guys on the podcast Robbie is
basically a fruitarian like he just eats
fruit all day long and he's managing his
type 1 diabetes and he you know he was
very transparent about all his numbers
and
uh and that just blows people's minds
like the the comments on the YouTube of
that are like bananas like people just
can't believe it they think he's lying
you know because it's like what fruit is
the thing you're supposed to avoid
you're supposed to avoid all these
sugars and here he is like doing the
exact opposite like how can this
possibly be true and the guy has like
more energy than anybody I've ever met I
know it's incredible he he literally
eats
upwards of a th000 gram of carbohydrate
in a day some some of his meals have
like 300 gam of carbs just in a bowl of
fruit and again if people are wondering
how is this even possible because you
know so and so told me that fruit is
terrible for diabetes and spikes of
blood glucose he's so sensitive to
insulin the insulin is working so well
because his saturated fat intake is
extremely low and he's a healthy body
weight that's a huge part of it and
that's something we haven't really
spoken about but you know people with
type two diabetes
if you're trying to reverse or or
reverse your your type two
diabetes the number one thing is weight
loss and a lot of the studies show that
there's sort of this like key number of
about 15
kilog of weight loss can achieve a
reversal or remission of of this type
two diabetes so so that's why again if
you start a keto diet and you lose all
this weight and all of a sudden you your
type two diabetes seem to be going away
a lot of it may be to the weight loss
right so that's again I'm not completely
excluding these other dietry patterns if
they can help people achieve weight loss
cuz that let's call a fat loss be a bit
more specific because you don't want to
lose muscle we want to hold on muscle is
very precious muscle is the sink or the
sponge that soaks up the glucose so we
want to hold on to as much of that as
possible it's not just an Aesthetics
thing it's it's quite important for many
aspects of Health but then losing body
fat that 15 kilog kilograms for some
reason is a number that people can
achieve some really good results if they
hit that and and in addition to just
this fear around
carbohydrates uh is a whole ideology
around grains that you had to sort of
deprogram yourself from so talk a little
bit about introducing grains back whole
grains we should say um back into your
diet and the impact of that yeah I
definitely demonized grains for many
many years I thought that they caused
inflammation ruined your God
Health you know would elevate your blood
glucose levels and this because I was
reading a lot of these paleo blogosphere
style of of you know the rhetoric there
is that whole grains are you know they
have lectin and poisons that they're
trying to kill you and you know all this
stuff and I definitely fell for it in
the beginning because it's a compelling
story it's a lot sexier than the the
current story of the whole food
plant-based one it just you know as you
mentioned before it seems to not get the
same Lim light as these really appealing
you know carnivore grains are trying to
kill you plant trying to kill you that
sort of Storytelling well those those
stories are very reductive and they're
often delivered in a package that comes
with a you know like a developed torso
and a lot of sort of conviction right
like you know we can get into that like
it is interesting that the plant-based
message doesn't track in the same way
because it's missing that that kind of
um uh you know it's not all tied up in
an alpha bow that is appealing to um a
young male I guess I should say right I
mean there are many developed torsos in
the plant-based world that are promoting
the message but as you say even in spite
of that it still doesn't quite get the
the spotlight that I think it deserves
and I think a lot of it is to do with
that alpha male you know rise of the
liver King the carnival craze of like
the the hunter right right there's
there's a whole story around uh
masculinity and a search for identity
and the connection between that Hunter
kind of paleo Primal uh what does it
mean to be a man that uh connects with a
certain dietary affiliation that
involves a lot of you know animal
protein right and when you strip that
away and you're talking about Whole Food
plant-based it just sounds beta soy boy
you know it's just a harder narrative to
you know it's just not going to it's not
going to track you know in an Instagram
re or in a Tik Tok in in the same way
which is problematic and is a longer
conversation around like how you story
tell and how you communicate um but you
as you know look you're an incredibly
fit dude you came to this after your
exploration in good faith in the Paleo
community and the keto community and um
discovered this plant- B based way of
eating and not only has it helped you
manage
um your diabetes it's it's fueled your
active lifestyle and you've become this
sort of proponent sort of an unlikely
proponent you know of a way of living uh
that is more sustainable healthier
longterm um without the compromises that
some would have you believe are part and
parcel of eliminating animal products
from your diet and when I when I made
the transition to to the plant-based
diet
I got to be honest the the animal ethic
side of it was not my focus because I
was very very determined to manage my
diabetes get those numbers under control
try to maintain my physique as the best
way I could I wasn't thinking about the
planet or the animals I got to be
honest but as you dive into you know
research and reading and documentaries
and just the community you get exposed
to those other two pillars that now
anemy potentially more than the health
side of this diet because I think a diet
attached to values and ethics is much
easier to maintain long term whilst a
diet attached to a little bit more
vanity and you know vanity and uh weight
loss and
Aesthetics right it's harder to maintain
long term so the the animal side of
things for me is is absolutely huge I
mean I always considered myself an
animal lover and I remember I got a I
was when I was paleo I was like making a
chicken broth and I had like the chicken
carcass I cooked up all of meat and I
had all the bones left over and I was
boiling it down and you know videoing
and put on social media and someone
slipped into my DMs and
said you know you're you're an abuser
you're you want to know where that
chicken came from watch this and then I
got into this dialogue with this person
I'm saying no no trust me I love animals
you I really I love animals you're wrong
about me you don't know me I didn't know
me I was so conscious I was
contradicting I was a hypocrite cuz I
told myself I loved animals and I I did
but I was eating some of them mhm and I
loved my dog but I was eating the other
animals who feel the same pain as my dog
suffering the same way as my dog and
arguably as intelligent as my dog so you
know I just didn't I didn't see it until
I started eating a plant-based diet for
health got exposed to these other two
pillars and then before I knew it I saw
some things that you just can't unsee
and I yeah I mean that holds me now you
holds me together yeah and my uh my
journey was not dissimilar it started
from a kind of vanity and health
perspective I didn't feel good I didn't
like the way that I looked and the the
ethics and the kind of environmental
considerations came much later but now
are much more they're on they're on a
parody with the you know it's like it's
a it's a lifestyle that checks all the
boxes right you can you can be more
gentle on the Planet it's more
compassionate towards our animal friends
it's actually in the best interest of
our health like it's almost as if nature
designed it that way you know what I
mean um and it's interesting to to you
know kind of be on the receiving end of
all the mental gymnastics that go into
rationalizing uh and you know these
other choices like oh actually you know
if you eat meat you're part of the
solution and uh the way to save the
planet is is more pasture you know more
more cattle pastures Etc um that really
don't hold up under close scrutiny right
which is a whole other podcast I don't
want to go too far down that rabbit hole
but um I think it gets confusing in the
influencer space uh
for uh for people who are um in a
position to be easily kind of massaged
oh yeah absolutely you see it now more
than I think that Nar has grown a lot
and I think people use it as an excuse I
know a lot of like let's be honest most
Alpha men who are eating meat today
aren't hunting at themselves they are
paying somebody to kill the animal for
them in what world does that make you a
man to pay you know for this industry to
exist so that you can eat meat I just
don't see that as a masculine
characteristic I mean I feel like I feel
more of a man now choosing not to
partake in something that goes against
my values to me that is a stronger a
stronger move than to go hey I'm only
going to eat meat but I'm going to make
sure that that person grows the animal
feeds the animal and kills the animal
for me I just you know it's it's more
masculine and takes more courage to take
a hard ethical stand that contravenes a
socially acceptable behavior and to do
it out of of compassion for the the
souls that can't speak for themselves
like to be a caretaker um to be a
protector uh but that is a harder once
again like a harder kind of you know
narrative to to spin um but I think it's
people like yourself who who hold
themselves out as an example you know
that's that's how you kind of um create
change in in this narrative and I think
the era of of you know activism is a
tricky thing like you need all kinds you
need people who are who are you know on
the far Edge and and uncompromising and
um speaking truth to power and then you
have people like Simon who are a little
bit more gentle and
um all those different voices have
different ways of connecting with people
uh but I found much like Simon that a
lot of the the sort of tools used by the
animal rights and vegan Community not to
work for me and I think are failing in
general and it's much better to be an
example like a healthy vibrant living
example of this lifestyle to attract
people who are curious about that and to
allow them in without judgment to have a
dialogue about what that might look like
for them that seems to it's a slower
yeah change I think but um yeah I mean I
think more effective I think the the
sort of more aggressive advocacy like
the example is the guy who sent me the
message saying you tortured that chicken
blah blah blah right that doesn't make
for me that's not going to you know make
you feel like you want to make that
change right it wasn't productive and
it's going to make you defensive correct
and I entrench you in that yeah yeah I
decided not to be that guy going forward
even though I want to say that to so
many people and I know it's true what's
true is not as important as what is
productive if you want to move the
needle talk a little bit about
overcoming your fear of suddenly sort of
dying on the vine like if you're going
to eat only plant-based protein well
that protein is inferior and it's
certainly um going to be substandard
compared to the way that I was eating
before like how have you um you know how
has your your Fitness changed or or your
gains you know have they been comp
compromise like how does what does that
look like the first couple weeks and
months uh I did feel a bit different um
I think I lost a little bit bit of
weight though because naturally when you
adopt a whole food plant-based diet
because the calorie density of the diet
is so low you are probably going to lose
some weight which is pretty awesome if
you're somebody who's overweight and
wants to lose weight in a way that's
kind of effortless in that you can eat
you know large volumes of food and not
have to count your calories and worry
too much about it so I lost a little bit
weight and I did feel a little bit
weaker in the beginning and that's when
I started messaging Simon I'm like mate
I need your help here the muscle's going
I feel a bit weak and I I wasn't
pretending everything was perfect
straight away and he said look you need
to eat more calories what are your
protein you know what are you eating at
the moment and I'd never ever had tofu
or Tempe ever in my life so he
introduced me to those two foods which
are now a staple of my diet I eat soy
foods every single day another myth that
we can bust another time
but I I had to learn what were the
protein Replacements to make in my diet
you know if I was take I was taking out
you know fatty cuts of meat and steak
and chicken eggs fish what am I going to
add back in and Simon helped me to to
develop sort of not a meal plan but
understand how to how to manufacture
that bowl every time I sat down to eat
like what are you going to put in that
bowl that's going to give you all the
nutrients and the protein and the
macronutrients that you need to still
perform play sport build mus and I've
gained probably you know a few kilos so
of what I like to think is lean muscle I
definitely you know didn't just blow up
so tofu Tempe beans lentils right and
the like right and supplement what about
all the lectins they everywh are they
are they destroying are you are you
toxic from all the lentil from all the
the the lectin well it turns out it's
easier to destroy lectin than it is for
lectin to destroy you and all you got to
do is cook them uh-huh or soak them or
both and you're going to pretty much
remove most of them right nobody's
eating raw beans well I don't know many
people know so you know this the idea
this whole Le I mean whatever it's a
whole other like you know but it is a
it's worth spending a minute to bust
that myth I know cuz there are a lot of
people who are afraid of lectin yeah I
mean the way Simon put it there's one
person who's responsible for that isn't
that incredible though like hats off to
that marketing team one person just
completely changed the diet of tens of
millions of people with one book I don't
even want to name him we don't okay but
Simon explained to me he goes look
lecons are destroyed when you cook them
if you look at epidemiological studies
of the longest living populations with
the least amount of chronic disease they
eat arguably the most lectin you know
they beans are a staple of their diet so
and just to tie it back into diabetes
those same populations who downbut ACR
the blue zones right yep not only do
they eat a lot of beans and lectins they
have quite a high carbohydrate diet and
they have the lowest amount of type 2
diabetes because their body weight
they're healthy body weight they're
active they move a lot they've got
wonderful bonds and connections with
family and Community they enjoy their
life and enjoy what they eat and the
last thing on their mind is are those
carbohydrates going to make me fat or
are it going to cause diabetes it's just
we we invented this problem because
people want to point the finger at
something to blame for the way they feel
today and it's always very reductive
it's like this is the one thing that you
need to remove or whatever and you know
I appreciate the nuance and the
complexity with which you describe your
condition like saying it's not just any
one of these things and if you do that
yes this will happen but then you have
to worry about this like our physiology
is complicated diabetes is complicated
nutrition is super complicated and
anybody who tells you this is the
solution that fits all and you just have
to do one this one thing or remove this
one thing I would be very wary of yeah
that that's the red flag if somebody has
the solution to to a problem that you
didn't even know was a problem so they
probably probably invented the problem
and then sell you the solution you know
to probably look for other people to
bounce some ideas off that's a problem
um which leads us to cgms so let's spend
a few minutes talking about this
obviously CGM a continuous glucose
monitor is a life or death very
important
um piece of technology that's
instrumental to any diabetic's life in
order to simply survive right you have
to be monitoring um your levels all the
time it's a it's crucial uh but we're in
a very interesting moment in which we're
seeing the the pioneering the innovation
of all kinds of Technology
um that's connecting the everyday person
with what's happening in their body uh
in real time whether it's your whoop
strap or your aura ring and now um these
companies where um you could do blood
work and they you know give you in-depth
analysis around that and of course an
added piece here is the CGM for the
first time ever being available to
Everyday People uh through various
companies and and this
allows anyone to wear one and to monitor
their own blood glucose in real time
there's an argument that this is a good
thing because anything that connects a
person to what their body is doing is is
knowledge and knowledge is power um but
there are also many people in the
diabetes Community who are upset about
this and uh and are concerned about um
uh you know what this means right so so
talk me through like your philosophy on
this because I'm I'm actually trying to
figure out where I stand on all of it I
am too to be honest I've given this a
lot of thought obviously um as somebody
who wears a CGM as you mentioned for
purposes that relate to keeping me alive
um it is a little bit funny seeing
people wearing them on the streets who
essentially don't need it it's more of a
want it's more of a fashion accessory or
a a badge of honor to show how much they
care about investing in their health
which is something to commend in some
ways you know if you care about your
health that much that you're willing to
wear a device that was invented for
people with
diabetes you got to sort of take a hat
off and say okay well you obviously care
about your health good on you but whilst
knowledge is
power if you don't understand or know
how to interpret the data that you're
collecting I believe it's kind of
useless and I think that people are
falling into the Trap of
wearing a CGM to collect data without
knowing exactly what it means or what
caused certain fluctuations in their
blood glucose levels and then again
pointing the finger at something that
may not be the actual cause of that
issue and I'm seeing cgms as a way for
people to justify low carb diets or keto
diets again it's not giving you that
whole picture it's only telling you what
the symptoms are which are those little
fluctuations in blood glucose but it's
not telling you about your insulin
sensitivity it doesn't tell you about do
you have uh you know fat building up in
cells that it shouldn't be which means
the insulin isn't working properly it
doesn't tell you that stuff so you know
people are the problem is people are
demonizing foods off the back of CGM use
it's happening they they they're eating
a carbohydrate saying see look at that
there's my glood blood glucose spike it
was because of mhm X yeah it gamifies
the whole thing where the goal is to
flatten that thing as much as possible
right um which is going to lead you to
making dietary choices that might not
have the best long-term um results right
right uh without that education piece I
think the education piece is super
important and I'm not sure that it's
quite in place um the contrary opinion
would be like listen I wore one for two
weeks and I learned a lot like I had no
idea that this food did this or when I
don't sleep well for example that was
something that I learned after you know
playing around with it for a little bit
like holy like when I don't when
I'm like not rested like it's all over
the place like that was something I
didn't realize or fully appreciate or
certain
um uh you know like certain foods are
acting in a way that I I wouldn't have
expected like when I eat a banana does
Spike higher than I would have thought
like okay I can file that away I'm not
going to make a big deal about it right
but it's a data point but but that but
the importance of that data point is
only in correlation to a whole other
world of understanding a Nuance that
really isn't part and parcel of what
that whole thing is about right now and
is that data point clinically meaningful
right that's the thing that cares like
and and there's there's a kind of a
weird shaming oh I had the spike that's
bad right is it bad we don't know but
what we do know is there's studies
looking at hb1c you know which is that
average 3mon glucose level um in normal
healthy people over you know thousands
of thousands of people big
epidemiological studies and and even
randomized studies but there's a clear
inflection point it's like a hockey
stick so the idea that the flatter the
better means you're going to have less
Health complications less chronic
disease you're going to live longer it's
not act I I'm not convinced that is true
right now today MH especially looking at
this inflection point at around I think
it's about 5.5% the hb1c whether your
A1C is 4.1 or 5.5 your risk for chronic
disease is pretty much the same same but
when it starts to go outside of that
normal range then you're going to see
some complications and your risk might
increase so if you're wearing CGM
because you're gamifying and you want to
be the flatter the better I'm not
convinced that that is an evidence-based
approach and I'm not convinced that
those spikes quote unquote spikes that
you're seeing Are CL clinically
meaningful or even relevant in the in in
your overall health right well I think
one of the problems is that the people
that are signing up to wear a CGM are
not the people who actually would
benefit from having one because we're in
as we mentioned earlier like there's a
massive rise in um metabolic disease
right now like there are so many people
who are either pre-diabetic or inching
ever so closely towards that who would
benefit from understanding how Haywire
their glucose regulation is but those
are not the biohackers the biohackers
are probably fine right like they don't
have to worry about it um but to the
extent that there could be a better way
to deploy these cgms as a tool in the
toolbox of stemming the rise of type 2
diabetes and pre-diabetes because by
2030 something like 50% of Americans are
expected to suffer from this like this
is a massive problem right and here's
something that could kind of help people
early as they're as they're nearing that
to understand that they're at risk I
think I think there's a benefit there
definitely secondarily you have on the
far other end of the spectrum Elite
athletes who are using super sapiens and
really understanding how nutrition
impacts performance and they're able to
extract really valuable D data
especially in the endurance space um you
know how do you get through an Iron Man
in high humidity and hydrate and keep
your glucose you know stable all that
kind of stuff I think is interesting at
The Cutting Edge of Athletics but but
that's a whole other you know world
right that's different from what we're
talking about um so I see your I see
your point and I think it's I think it's
very valid um the other question I had
is because I've heard this because I've
talked about cgms on the podcast before
and and people from uh the diabetes
Community who who get sort of agitated
about that um have led me to believe
like is there like a shortage of these
I'm certainly like if there's only so
many cgms and there are people for whom
wearing one of these is life or death I
would rather those people have them than
you know the biohackers out there who
are just noodling around with it right
um and there's a there's a an expense
thing too like how does that work in if
more people are using them do we reach a
certain scale where they become cheaper
and more affordable to the people that
need them or is there a scarcity of
these devices Al together that make it
important that um we conscious of that
if we're going to you know try to play
around with one rich I don't know the
answer to that I understand that some
people who who have diabetes uh may not
be able to get their hands on them
because like you say they're attached to
the arm of somebody who's a you know a a
gymgo who just wants to use it as a fat
loss tool which I don't believe it is um
I haven't seen I don't know anyone who
doesn't have a CGM because there's a
shortage of them in Australia it's
subsidized so the government pays the
bulk majority of of that that fee it was
only it only came into um use I think it
was maybe a year ago now or less
actually just a few months where it used
to be like $5,000 a year to have one and
now it costs maybe 10 bucks a sensor so
it's much much cheaper so it's
affordable now for people with diabetes
in Australia I don't know about in the
US I have heard that though that people
can't get their hands on them but then
the other argument as you mentioned is
the supply demand and if if you can
increase the scale does it become
cheaper for every body but I just don't
know that these companies producing them
are there yet to create well if we look
at the price of insulin we can oh my we
can we can predict you know how that
might play out but you know just going
back to one other utility that I can see
a CGM working
is imagine if we put a CGM on the people
who are high risk right so you go to
your doctor your doctor sees it your
high risk maybe it's for family history
or it's to do with your BMI away
circumference or whatever other
metabolic conditions you have you might
even have diabetes unknowingly and we
could diagnose a large amount of of
people with diabetes just by using the
cgms right because a lot of the people
who are undiagnosed aren't visiting
their doctor they're not tracking any
data whatsoever so they're walking
around with with diabetes not knowing it
which is a silent killer essentially
increasing your risk of cardiovascular
disease and all these other metabolic
issues but if if cgms were accessible
and cheap and everyone wore one then
we're probably going to diagnose you
know millions and millions of people and
there is something about seeing it on
your screen right after you eat
something like wait you mean when I do
that this happens like I didn't know
that that creates a connection with your
body and also um provides that sense of
agency like oh but when I do this that
that then this happens like oh cool like
you become much more engaged with
yourself um and that can then lead you
down a path of being more engaged in
other areas like once you experience a
certain positive result then you're
encouraged and motivated you know
explore further yeah right it's like
kind of wearing like a step tracker I
mean that simple data input of how many
steps did I do today may make you go to
the gym it might make you choose a
healthier meal there's so it's snowballs
um so yeah I mean there are cases where
I can see it being very beneficial I
just worry that we may be uh misusing it
at the moment I'm not sure that I'm not
going to stamp yeah no I I understand
that and I do like I said I do think
that there is a lot of room for
improvement in the education piece
because it isn't as simple as like keep
it flat no definitely not it's not that
simple it's very complicated but the
other thing is like if you're only doing
finger Pricks like I was for many many
years before I had the courage to wear
wear a device um and I say courage
because I didn't want to have this
physical device attached to me 20 47
that represented my condition so I was
doing these finger Pricks every single
day but you're only getting a little
snapshot of this very dynamic system
that's in flux all the time so if I did
a finger prick at 10:00 a.m. and the
next one I did was at 3:00 p.m. I have
no idea what happened in between those
hours did my blood glucose rise very
high and come down did it stay flat did
it go low and come back you just don't
know so the data that you get from the
CGM as you say you pick up your phone
and you can see in real time these
little dots you know
in graph form you can see the trends and
patterns you can learn you know at this
time of day naturally my blood glucose
goes up you know because in the morning
you've got cortisol flowing and your
blood glucose will kind of rise and at
this time of day it naturally goes down
and you just you learn so much in real
time so that that is the beauty of the
technology it's amazing technology one
of the other things I learned using it
is how my body responds to different uh
versions of Tim restricted eating and
and intermittent fasting
um and I went through a period where I
was kind of doing this one meal a day
and I would eat it too I would eat like
a big dinner but I would do it late at
night and then watching what would
happen to uh my blood glucose over the
period of when I was sleeping was like
very surprising what did it do tell me
well it would just it would like Drop
and then it would like Spike at like 2:
in the morning and that was typically
when I would like wake up you know it
was I was like wow this is like wreaking
havoc on me like I wouldn't have thought
that and I since have realize like oh
actually when I eat smaller meals
throughout the day I have better results
I have more restful sleep I don't have
this you know strange looking graph that
happens in the middle of the night and I
could feel it but being able to match
what I was experiencing with those data
points you know helped convince me that
you know I needed to like do things a
little bit differently that's very
interesting I mean that that's a
phenomenon that happens to people with
type one a lot is if you have a a very
large dinner close to bed
mhm especially if it's packed with a lot
of fat because that slows down gastric
emptying so the rate at which the food
leaves your digestive system enters the
bloodstream and carbohydrates right so
you basically you're slamming your foot
on the brakes you've got all this food
in your stomach waiting to digest and
then like 6 hours later it starts to
enter your blood stream and you can have
these massive spikes like 6 hours later
the classic example for people with
taipon is a pizza it's just the one food
that I don't know anyone who's figured
it out because it's got a lot of cheese
saturated fat refined carbohydrates big
serve you eat that 6 hours later your
blood glucose spikes and by that time
the insulin that you gave for the meal
is long gone out of the system so it's
this mismatch between the rate of
glucose entering the system and the rate
of which your insulin is working or now
it's gone so I never thought about that
though in people without diabetes and
I'm actually really surprised that
that's the case I would not have
predicted that I would have thought that
your pancreas would would uh handle that
naturally you know now you're scaring me
no no no no no I'm not saying anything
yeah I'm not diagnosing anything right
here but yeah it's very interesting well
I don't do that anymore okay um but I'm
interested in whether you've played
around with as an experimentor with
intermittent fasting or Tim restricted
eating and and how that kind of operates
as as a type one yeah absolutely I've
played around with everything at this
point I think that um the the fasting is
is a really good tool I find it you know
it makes it a lot easier if you're in
range if your blood glucose is in range
and then you aren't adding these inputs
to the system it could be easy to stay
in range the problem that I was running
into was similar to you I was eating
meals that were too big I was so hungry
by the time it was you know time to
break the fast that I was overeating the
the the volume of the meal which delays
the gastric emptying and then there was
that mismatch as I mentioned between the
insulin and the glucose so I but I I
think I just need to learn to sort of
scale back the size of the meals and
it's definitely a good tool it can
absolutely work and some people just
like you some people just aren't hungry
in the morning I like to train fasted I
don't want to eat a big meal before I
before I train so it it works
practically for lots of people to fast
until you're hungry it makes sense but
you haven't found like a specific
protocol that works for you I haven't I
I mean I haven't played around with it
that much but for me when I do the fast
I I I backload my calorie intakes I'll
fast in the morning and eat more from
sort of noon onwards but I know people
who do the opposite and they frontload
their calories and they get some pretty
good results with that so I think that
it definitely does matter the protocol
that you choose and what time you decide
to do your fast first your eating window
um I haven't tried the the front loading
yet so maybe you're enticing me to do
another experiment the front loading
yeah it's like I just I I don't want to
wake up in the morning and eat eat a
bunch of food same I want to go out and
train right away right
um if I'm training really hard I can't
always do a fasted workout session in
the morning right um because that will
impair my ability to do it the next day
and the next day and the next day you're
always like you're eating not for that
session but you're kind of eating for
the following day right um in order to
recover and repair um but in general if
I'm not training super hard yeah like
just get out and get it done first thing
is that including rather than eating a
huge meal right when I wake up in the
morning like I just never want to do you
don't have to do it that way what you
could do is do your fasted workout so
what time would you do that workout is
early 7 in morning so 7 or 8 in the
morning you do your workout you're home
by 9:10 that's when your eating window
can begin so it's like a postmeal
breakfast you can do that sort of maybe
it's 10 till 4:00 I don't know 10 to
whatever that could be your eating
window but again if you love food and
you don't have metabolic issues and you
don't need to be adding all these tools
into your life then perhaps you don't
have to do it yeah it's it's it's just
it's a it's what's in Vogue right now
like what is your protocol you know what
I mean like my protocol is enjoying my
life uh which kind of brings us to I
want to I want to spend the last part of
our conversation talking about um good
good practices for just
eating um a healthy Whole Food
plant-based diet like we talked a little
bit about the protein but you know
Common misconceptions or confusions
around things like Omega-3s and vitamin
D and b12 like how are you making sure
that you're not deficient like how do
you think about these things in terms of
not only how you function as a fit
active person but also um longterm like
how are you eating to Sid step to man
not only manage your diabetes but also
sidestep heart disease which is a risk
factor for your condition um and to
prevent cognitive decline and all the
other kind of Downstream um
things that you know we need to be
thinking about sooner rather than later
the way that I've constructed my dietry
pattern is the the front of mine for me
the most important thing the most
important principle is diversity plant
diversity I need to try to get as many
different unique plants in there as
possible because they all come with
unique nutrients some have protein some
have carbs some have fat I just need
diversity there and also for God Health
right if you're just sticking to three
or four vegetables um I would argue that
your microbiome health is probably not
as Rob Tim Spector 30 plants a week
right which should be really easy
actually like if you're actually eating
a robust diverse Whole Food plant-based
diet you're probably getting 30
different plants a day I would say so
yeah I think I could do that in a meal
sometimes even um so plant diversity is
key when I making that plate or Bowl I'm
thinking of the three macronutrients but
I will say that I have to think about
those because I'm living with diabetes
so every time I make a meal I have to
eye off that plate and understand how
many grams of carbohydrate are in the
meal how many grams of protein how many
grams of fat because the interplay
between those three macros will
influence the dose of insulin that I
have to give and I it took me years of
learning how to understand what's in the
foods and Counting the carbohydrates you
know because I I would in the beginning
I would have a food scale I would weigh
every single ingredient that went in I'd
plug it into an app it would spit out
you know the information regarding the
macros and the calories and then I would
give my insulin dose thankfully now I'm
at the point where I can just look at it
and understand what to do but I want to
try get
30 30 grams of protein per per main meal
right and I get that from tofu Tempe
legumes you know beans chickpeas um
lentils some nuts and seeds um I'm
trying to eat carbohydrates at all my
meals as well and i' like to get it from
whole grains um and then a big B big
base this is where the volume comes I
can get my volume that fills me up from
the lower calorie density you know
nutrient-dense leafy greens cruciferous
non-starchy vegetables um if you stick
to that and you eat 3 meals a day you're
pretty much going to be good but if you
really want to bulletproof it you know
I'll take a protein um supplement after
workouts just because I enjoy it I
actually like the flavors and I can make
a smoothie or a you know like a sort of
like protein ice cream or something and
that's the enjoyment that's the enjoying
life factor that you just mentioned like
for me that people say oh it's it's
processed and I don't care I like the
way I like the taste it's not bad for
you and it helps me hit my protein
targets so you're getting maybe an extra
30 G so you're looking at I don't know
uh 100 120 g to 150 sometimes it depends
sometimes I'll have two scoops over a
day or I'll have an extra serve of Tempe
you know so I'm not I'm not counting and
I'm not being granular but roughly 30
per main meal maybe a snack and maybe
that protein shake gets me approximately
1.5 gram of protein per kilo of body
weight roughly and how do you think
about Omega-3s DHA DHE EA there's a lot
of discussion around that and whether
you can adequately meet your body's
requirements on a plant-based diet look
I I try to get it from food as much as I
can I eat a lot of whole flax meal hemp
seeds Cher seeds um but I also take a
supplement to again bulletproof those
those nutrients and and I'm not afraid
to take an essential it's called
essential Aid it's a one that I like to
take it's called you know Simon's
UL yeah so I take that every day it's
got B12 vitamin D algae oil for those um
instead of fish oil you take the algae
oil same thing um and yeah that's my
daily my daily dose I just take that and
I bulletproof my diet and I do blood
work very very frequently and I have no
issues and I'm healthy and when people
come to you and say uh tell me about
your diet or um you know how are you
doing what you're doing uh what are some
of the misconceptions around not
only uh you know eating plant-based as a
type 1 diabetic but um just life as a T1
diabetic in general and also being this
kind of like you know fit person who
likes to train like what are some of the
things you would like to not necessarily
correct the record but you know sort of
misconceptions out there around um how
you're eating and and how you're living
well I mean the main misconceptions are
and most people have seen these floating
around on the
Internet is that you need to eat animals
to get your protein which you don't so
people's major concern is where am I
going to get my protein is there enough
protein in Plants um and yes there is
spoiler alert um what about all those
carbohydrates isn't it too high in carbs
and and and this is a fair point that
people make is what if they want to do a
low carb version of a plant-based diet
that's getting a little tricky now and I
think that if you're going to do a
plant-based diet you've got to be
willing to surrender in certain aspects
of your life and say you know what
perhaps I need to amend my relationship
with carbohydrates and adopt this
dietary pattern instead of trying to
make my dietry patent meet my
carbohydrate goals mean like a keto
plantbase right it it can be done but a
lot of the the protein sources that you
get from plants come with carbohydrates
so it is I Think It's Tricky I haven't
tried it and I that's one experiment I
don't really want to try right now um
but some people want to try do that
version and it's possible but I really
think that I think we need to like zoom
out a little bit and look long term what
do you want to achieve long term if you
want to achieve a diet that is attached
to values and ethics a diet that makes
you feel satiated in a full that
contains all the nutrient you need that
you can build muscle and you can still
reduce your risk of chronic disease
reduce your risk of developing
cardiovascular disease our biggest
killer then the plant-based diet is
ticking all of those boxes and some
people might find that they can't stick
to it that you know they have digestive
discomfort or it's just not for them
well then you can do an 85% plant-based
diet and get a lot of the probably all
of the benefits to be honest other than
the ethical side environmental perhaps
but most of the health benefits come
from going 85% plant-base I would say
and I think that there is research to
support that so yeah you don't have to
go 100% but maybe you start at 80 85 and
you nudge your way to 100 and some
people will be surprised at how kind of
easy it is to do once you're in the in
the groove what are what are some ways
of of getting people started with that I
mean there's certain people you know it
sounds like you just were like okay I'm
in and you just snap your fingers and
you're all in overnight I had a similar
kind of way of getting into it most
people are not like that you know like
how do I dip my toe in this how do I you
know break up with some of my favorite
foods that um I feel powerless to put
behind like how do you Embark upon this
journey in a way that you're focused on
creating new sustainable habits that
will last you the test of time and not
just get you through a 30-day experiment
well I think going back to what we spoke
about before is if you can attach your
dietary change to something a lot deeper
than just vanity or Aesthetics and you
think about ethics or environment or
something a little bit stronger if you
have a pull towards that it's going to
be easier to to do it but I think
understanding the swaps you've got to
make so you know maybe it starts with
reducing the portion size of the Animal
product on your plate you don't have to
eliminate it entirely but just reduce it
and then maybe the 50% reduction that
you've taken away you put in with beans
or tofu or Tempe or something
plant-based so you're still getting the
protein dose you need half of it may be
coming from plant protein the other half
from animal protein and then slowly you
can just nudge towards the plant protein
over time adding new vegetables and
fruits and trying new things like you
know I hadn't eaten fruit Like A
diversity of fruit in many many many
years and you forget how Bloody good
fruit is like it's really delicious and
there are so many different it's not
just apples and oranges like take a take
a leaf out of Robbie's book go to a
market and fall in in love with the
variety that guy has you know a a weird
like romantic obsession with like durian
and like you know like it's like what is
the fetishization that certain people
have with durian like Doug Evans is the
same way it's so funny like I'm like you
guys should just get married or get a
room like it's weird you know it is
bizarre I I mean I don't understand it
I'm not that way inclined but yeah they
they've romanticized that relationship
for sure with I mean Robbie knows the
name names of fruits that I've never
heard of you know he's he shows us on
Instagram like this strange looking
thing that where people normal people
have bookshelves he has like shelves and
he puts all fruit there I mean it's like
yeah anyway but I guess look you got to
fall in love with the food you're eating
you got to enjoy it that's sustainable
you know and if it's healthy food that's
even better I mean a lot of people fall
in love with foods that aren't so good
for them so I think if you're going to
move the needle you've got to be willing
to experiment you've got to be willing
to try new foods make it taste good this
is the thing if it tastes you're
not going to eat it and a lot of people
tend to say ah tofu Yak it's so Bland
yeah marinate it make it whatever you do
to your chicken you can use the same
thing for your tofu or use the tofu as
the the canvas and you know make it
tasty find recipes online you know
there's so many great plant-based
recipes and homemade dressings and
sauces and just you got to find a way to
actually make it taste good I think
that's an important one because it's
really easy to eat some boring meals and
go no it wasn't for me yeah because you
had boring meals make them enjoyable
yeah I think you have to make it fun and
and not uh make it so pressurized uh and
adhere to some kind of perfectionist
ideal um such that when you have a weak
moment or you lapse into some old you
know kind of habit that doesn't serve
you it's like okay that's fine just get
back to what's the next best choice you
know how can I like like find new
recipes and and and turn it into you
know something that's just that that
that ignites your curiosity and doesn't
feel like heavy and burdensome yeah I I
agree and I think that it's easier now
than it ever has been if you go on
social media and you follow a few people
who have you know amazing recipes and
they teach you how to do it from scratch
I mean there is definitely the side of
it that people don't talk about enough
is sort of like culinary skills like
actually learning how to cook is quite
important because I mean even in Bondi
there's a shortage of plant-based
restaurants I mean there's a handful of
them but not all restaurants are going
to have a plant-based option so a lot of
your eating is probably going to be done
at home which is probably healthier for
you anyway because you know what you're
putting in the food so you got to get
those skills and learn how to cook
that's probably another good good place
to you do all your cooking I do a lot of
it yeah so when you go out what what
happens when you go out to eat and like
how do you manage like the
social uh aspect of the whole thing cuz
I feel like that's really the Achilles
heel uh people don't want to be
problematic in Social settings they
don't want to you know have uh you know
be in situations where like they are
making other people uncomfortable
because they have a certain way of
eating and it just becomes tricky and
complicated yeah the social aspect is
very interesting
because I mean for me it's actually
double-edged because on one hand your
life depends on it like you have this is
your is your job right right but also
it's different you have you have an
excuse that everyone is going to be like
cool with and I hate that I hate I hate
leaning on Diabetes as the excuse which
is easy to do when I go out it's like a
guys you know I have to eat this because
my diabet it's an easy thing to do but I
try my best not to do it and I told
myself from day one I will I know it's
not my fault I have it but it's my
responsibility to manage it and I'm
never going to use it as an excuse cuz I
want to empower myself to do whatever
the hell I want to do in this world and
if I'm leaning on it even once as a
crutch it's just going to trickle into
other things in my life and I don't want
that to be an excuse so you know what
just got to own it so when I go out with
friends and you know we finished rugby
season Once We went to a pub here in
Bondi and all the boys ordered burgers
and chips and steak and stuff and I you
know really quietly pulled the waitress
aside and I said hey actually I I I
don't eat meat have you got anything on
the menu That's vegan or plant-based and
she's like yeah we'll whip something up
for you
anyway all the food comes out all these
Burgers line up the table and then I get
this like rainbow bowl like this Buddha
bowl most beautiful looking thing and
the boys all look at me and they go hey
that looks really good I didn't see that
on the menu and I'm like yeah I just
asked you know for the way she they said
I wonder if we can get some so I mean
look if you can just own it and be
willing to I was willing for them to say
the comments whatever soy boy whatever
they wanted to say I owned it I held my
ground I enjoyed my meal and it turns
out that they wanted to taste it too so
yeah I love that that's cool um well I
just think that you're you know a really
powerful example of this Lifestyle Young
vibrant living with type 1 diabetes but
not in a way that it's inhibiting you in
any meaningful way and uh the fact that
you have you know in good faith lived
these other Lifestyles and have kind of
arrived here and this is a sustainable
solution that's working for you is
amazing and I think that uh that gives
you a certain resonance you know when
you talk about it that that's really
powerful I appreciate that yeah man so I
appreciate you coming to talk to me
today you have this website Drew's daily
dose uh you've got all kinds of
resources there for anybody who's
curious about how you do what you do
you've got these five pillars we talked
about nutrition and exercise but there's
mindfulness and you know we talked about
managing blood glucose and all of that
um but you have lots of tools resources
uh and kind of a whole protocol yeah I
mean I was one part of the story that I
didn't mention was after being diagnosed
I went back to UNI and got a degree as a
diabetes educator because I thought you
know I'm in the perfect position to
educate people you know I'm I've got
this family of doctors I'm educated I'm
an exercise physiologist I'm diabetes
educator I'm living with diabetes how
could I not share this information so
Drew delos was my way of s of figuring
out a protocol that five pillar protocol
to help people and I I was Consulting a
lot online and doing coaching and one-on
ones but you know now I'm at the point
where I really want to reach way more
people at once and Simon and I have got
some really fun ideas for some online
courses that we want to start generating
around certain Niche groups and diabetes
obviously being a huge part of it and I
just released you know after 12 years of
doing all this social media stuff or
whatever it is um I just released my
first like training program like an on
online training program you know
position training for strength and
hypertrophy cardio Zone 2 I know you
love your Zone 2 zone 5 all like
evidence-based protocols and an ebook
with you know like 16,000 words 50
pages you know explaining the state of
the evidence in terms of you want to
gain muscle and and you build muscle
build strength and improve your
cardiovascular fitness for Health and
Longevity this was my way of distilling
all of that into this ebook with like
videos of every exercise and 8we
programs and so I just I actually just
only released that a couple weeks ago so
yeah that's pretty cool exciting um and
uh and uh really interesting I mean we
could have done a whole podcast on you
know endurance training strength
training hit high intensity all of that
like I know that you and Simon have
spoken at length about that on various
podcasts so um you have plenty more to
share do this again if you find yourself
in Los Angeles um yeah so if you're if
you're digging on in his message like I
said there's 12 at least 12
conversations between you and Simon on
the proof and and your website lots of
stuff out there for you to kind of learn
more and dig a little bit deeper is
there anywhere else that you want to
direct people you know I'm active on
Instagram that's the only social media
account I've got through his daily dose
um and Simon and I are running some
Retreats now actually oh yeah did you
just do the B one it's in October it's
coming up yeah coming up in October is
it sold out we might be opening a second
week so there's definitely space and we
plan to make that the best week ever and
I know you just did one right in was
yeah in Italy a little bit different
than the one that you're doing but it
looked cool I was checking it out and
the location looks insane beautiful
location world class surfing wave right
out the front of the resort we're going
to make it very education heavy as Simon
and I love our our science and education
so everyone's getting blood work right
every's getting blood work probably
going to get Dexter scans as well and we
want to make it not just a week but like
an ongoing protocol we'll still check in
with people and stay on top of their
blood work and all their goals and build
a community in person and online and
just keep it going I mean look this is
Simon's he's done all the hard work I'm
definitely I came on as the exercise
physiologist but he's so generous that
he's you know taking me along for the
ride so I'm just so grateful in so many
ways for him I mean we're here in his
Studio waves Bondi he got me on this
plant-based diet we're doing these
Retreats together so you know in his
Studio yeah I mean he's an unbelievable
person like when I was here in January I
mean he just hooked me up and is so uh
you know open and and like you said
generous with with what he has he's a
he's a really extraordinary person great
I'm very grateful to have in my life me
too and brought us together here in his
home so that's right shout out to Simon
of course uh I don't know when this
podcast is going to go up but it'll
probably be sold out by that time but if
not go to the proof.com there's a whole
kind of landing page there with more
information on that and uh this was cool
man thank you thank you so much I can't
believe we did this here in Bondi it's
quite surreal for me I'm a little jet
lag I hope I didn't come off too
incoherent but I just let you talk the
whole time you seemed very awake
excellent thank you drew cheers thank
you so much
peace that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant powerway as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. roll.com if
you you'd like to support the podcast
the easiest and most impactful thing you
can do is to subscribe to the show on
Apple podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube
and leave a review and or comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
man management and of course our theme
music was created by Tyler Patt Trapper
Patt and Harry matys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plants
[Music]
namaste